^- Well why do they make 'em?
^- Because it says green and it makes us feel better.
I know this isn't a sexy topic
and it's not about the Kardashians,
but please just watch it.
You're gonna learn something new.
Hi, I'm Ari, and we're here at BuzzFeed
where we're very green.
We have compostable silverware and compostable cups.
But what if I told you these items
^do not belong in a regular compost?
^What do you think when you hear something is compostable?
^- I think it's supposed to break down
and like go back to the Earth.
- What type of plastic are you holding, do you know?
- That's a good question.
- Compostable in industrial facilities
which may not exist in your area.
Not suitable for home composting.
^- Compostable plastic can't be put into regular compost
^because it doesn't get hot enough.
Biodegradable plastics need to be heated up
^to over 120 degrees fahrenheit to break down.
And you can't recycle it,
because it'll harm the quality
of the other plastics being recycled.
So it goes right in the trash.
- Then why are we making 'em?
- Well they're not made from oil, so that is good.
- Oh, okay, they're made from
- They're made from.
- Like corn right?
- Plant materials.
- Yeah.
So, are compostable and biodegradable plastics
really better for our environment?
And are any of these materials being reused?
Let's go to a facility in LA to find out.
^- Okay, so just watch your head.
^You're okay, I'm the one they (mumbles).
^(Ari laughs)
(persistent music)
^We recycle as much as we can in that blue bin,
^but because of the way the technology is today,
we miss about 10%.
So a secondary MRF, which we've just seen here
takes the material that's missed,
or the material they choose not to sort.
^For example, bioplastics.
^(machine running)
- Are you the only MRF on the West Coast
that's processing bioplastics?
- Yes.
- So you're probably only processing
a very small percentage of the bioplastics?
- Very, very small.
- Where do your bioplastics go that you sort?
- We send them to a facility in the East Coast
and they wash it, grind it
and they're trying to figure out what to do with it,
because they don't have enough to recycle.
- [Ari] Most people aren't recovering bioplastics,
so are bioplastics even better?
- Well, it depends, it's like the chicken and egg.
We don't have enough grade a system to recycle 'em,
but if we create the system then we sort it,
then we can recycle it.
Bioplastics is another way to create the same product
using a renewable resource.
- So, if you're tired of our disposable culture
and green-washing, why not try some reusable options?
Like, bring your own thermos for your coffee
or your own bag to the grocery store.
I know, it's overwhelming, it can be difficult.
Just start small, and you can make little changes.
I have faith in you.
Okay, do you think we got it?
- Yeah.
- Do I look insane?
- No, no.
- (laughs) Okay.
You did it, good job.
Every time you get through a video
about the environment a fairy is born.